hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello
why now hello hello hello hello hello
hello how are you it's a fine lovely day
for a trivia murder party hello hello
music Scott oh hello hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello and
welcome to jack box party pack number
six funny story
jed the jack box party packed people
they contacted me early this morning
saying that they gave me a code and they
said that I could make videos about it
yeah I had their full permission to do
this so this game is not out yet let me
make that very clear game is not out
doesn't come out until like later this
month but but big but I said it's
unlikely but that means that I could
start playing this game with you guys
today
right and they said yeah sure I told
them it was unlikely and yeah Here I am
ready to play jack box party pack 6 with
you lovely beautiful people out there so
hello hello welcome if you're watching
this in the future
this game is best played live because
this game in this game you guys can play
with me and in this game one of the
things that I'm most excited about is
there is now a sequel to trivia murder
party which is probably mine and
everyone else's favorite game in this
entire series of games so yes we will be
playing trivia burner party the sequel
along with some other new fun games such
as role models no wait no stop don't go
you didn't want to click on it now yeah
go back please thank you no wait no go
back no go back
No
go back this is the back foot you can
see how this arrow here seems like it
might be a back button but apparently
it's not like role models and joke boat
and dictionary em and then push the
button which is not a multiplayer game
but we've got a lot of games here that
we're gonna play together so buckle up
get ready
bust out ye olde phones because oh oh
we're gonna be playing some oh we're
gonna be playing some trivia murder
party ah we're gonna be how are you guys
doing today by the way are you good I'm
just waiting for a few more people to
get in here and then we're gonna get
started if you're watching this from the
future buckle up and try to answer along
with us I don't think you can play in
the future I don't dig technologies to
that point yet Bart we will see what
happens but how are you guys doing
you beautiful wonderful beautiful
wonderful people you who you you you you
beautiful wonderful people how are you
doing out there are you feeling good
about yourself you sure cuz you're
unstoppable you're unflappable your
flaps can't be flapped you're unbeatable
undeniable irreplaceable you're
essential in every machination that I
have you're an important target so don't
worry you will do great things you
beautiful lovely people wait how wait
that doesn't make any sense how are you
watching this from the future right now
but you're in chat right because you see
how that doesn't make any sense that
doesn't make any sense at all because
how would you be watching this from the
future right now you know I might be a
little bit gullible and maybe halfway
too stupid but I don't think that you
can trick me that way because I'm pretty
sure that I can do this alright who's
ready we're gonna go into this trivia
murder party number two if you want to
play this for yourself all you have to
do is go to jack box TV and wait for the
ode to pop up when the code pops up
that's when you can play along with us
let me make sure all the settings are
good extended timers I've got this on
relative low latency so it shouldn't be
that essential
I've got subtitles on yeah this seems
probably pretty good okay let's do this
oh wait hang on no no looking I gotta
get this okay here we go okay hold on
all right you ready all right ding-dong
here we go three two one so if you want
to go and play the game you can enter
that room code but also even if you
don't get into the room right now you
can join the audience and you can play
and one of the good things about trivia
murder party is that the audience's role
is actually a significant role whereas
other jackbox party games it isn't
always that essential but in this one
there's the possibility so all are
welcome please join I think the maximum
number in a room is 10,000 so I don't
think that we're gonna fill it up just
yet but if you do there's still a lot of
space before we get to that point so get
in now and even if we start the game you
can still join the game halfway through
so let's see how do you play I don't
know yet I haven't figured it out so
we're gonna we're gonna learn together
this is my first time playing this game
too so just let me let me let me figure
it out and then we're gonna go okay I'm
gonna start this in ten nine eight seven
six five four three two
yeah okay that's good enough you could
still join even after we get started
here so if you haven't joined yet just
join everyone know the code everyone
spread the code for several generations
in unrelated news the trivia puerto
birdy killer is still on the loose
[Music]
I'm being held against my will this is
your wake-up call
prepare to die welcome to to the another
party behind he can get away was a trap
well you into a deem of life or death
survive
I can't it's still better than just
sitting in your hotel rather than
watching TV news yeah I went there
all right first question oh we're going
right now
John James Audubon was well known for
drawing and painting okay
you guys gotta let me know the volume
[Applause]
yeah let me know if the volume still out
in the game okay well good I'm hope to
make this more interesting
you haven't died that you can give to
whoever you want to make their odds
worst exciting ouch yay no wound the
player with the highest total dies okay
I'm doing it yeah yes too
haha both of you died just one girl okay
oh okay is that better on the game
probably oh good good I mean last
release I'm not bad remember that
players are still players just more
see-through flame and you just might
steal someone else's like Thorson win
the game oh by the way the audience is a
player now could win the whole freakin
game [ __ ] Jim you can join the audience
at any time
wait okay so in this one the audience
can win
oh [ __ ] movie Oh show me if I win
service breakfast is all apart I know
what that means okay I got it cuz I'm
smart in my big brain guys my big brain
is so big huge just sometimes my head
just explodes because of how smart I am
[Music]
god I'm so smart yeah the audience is
pretty stupid alive time for
consequences I'm going to dictate a
message to you write down as much of why
I say as you can that's easy then the
one else will be typing - that's easy
and if anyone does a better job than you
you die that's easy
and the letter begins now
dear people of the neighborhood have you
seen this cat it has the eyes of a cat
that has seen far too much and answers
to the name muffin it has been missing
for five years but I have reason to
believe it's immortal
please do not feed it for it eats only
darkness tardes up okay your ass kicked
by my amazing thumb skills I kicked your
on the bathroom it's so weird I love
having those players in this game but
all the other ghosts in this hotel scare
the crap out of me like who your deeper
self I didn't need to know that in any
way let's try another one
if I wanted to push you off the top of a
tower purely hypothetical which of these
would provide the longest fall mark is
the god of thumbing people can we not
make that a thing because that'll break
yeah what is it please don't be your
penis
there's nothing more fun than fogged up
news why
that's a weird things egg the ghost of
my Aunt Mildred is riding on this mirror
he has her own consistent handwriting
now Aunt Mildred is going to write a
different word but so will all the safe
players throw a word on the mirror and
maybe you'll trick someone into thinking
it's Aunt Mildred some ahead and start
writing pay attention to the words as
they appear and try to spot my auntie so
many convincing words to choose from now
type the word that Aunt Mildred wrote or
you die the wheel Aunt Mildred please
stand up
that's a weird mistake
[Laughter]
[Music]
and what players left alive will go to
the final round next question what does
buddy say are the four major food groups
for elves oh I know this Amy would be so
disappointed if I got this wrong
like Amy would be very upset with me if
I got this sort of time she wouldn't do
anything but her disappointment would be
punishment enough
[Music]
Oh Oh your ghost got it wrong
nobody huh okay let's keep moving okay
which of these snacks has a toxic show I
don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
what's your bet against me oh I put
splited alright this seems soon we
wouldn't be still a wall it's very
unfair
go ducks uh what did it mean
ah you've made it so far
continued escape I'm going to give you a
category ah after you please trakula tap
each answer that fits the category and
then press submit let's see the right
answers closer to the exit if you've
gotten any of those right oh wait did
you think it was going to be just you
if it goes catches you he'll steal your
life force then they can try to escape
and win the game here's everyone's next
question and they get a virgin shout
them catch up to you I don't know I am
the worst at this last segment I always
lose at the end here like I always lose
I don't know why dad's just the worst
I'm terrible at sports you know I'm
garbage I'm dirt efficient [ __ ] I don't
know I'm so bad at the lightning round
I'm so bad at the lightning round
so bad oh the audience is doing pretty
good I don't know what happens if the
audience wins can they do the efficiency
balloons
I don't know I'm not the biggest game of
Thrones buff and I don't think anyone is
after that last season but hey Wow hey
look at me hey keep it up on your butt
oh oh oh I don't know
Harvey's little stop I don't know I I
really have no idea I have no idea
ah crap well there's Oh little ones well
that's easy
maybe I don't know
what didn't get it wrong we know
but it was what what what ah crap damn
it back nabbit
I knew you stole some yummy lifeforce
the darkness approaches apparently it do
constellations okay I'm thinking that
maybe I gotta give that if we do this
again I got to do a little bit more
extendo timers Oh God
dingus dang it maybe I can get this Oh
Oh
I'm going for the slam dunk
[Music]
[Applause]
not to get all the right answers to a
steep
[Applause]
[Music]
every time every time I even went into
it being like I'm probably gonna lose
that'd be fine I'm okay with that and
then it lets me get a little bit of
false folk I don't watch Black Mirror I
don't pay attention episode names who
give me false Oh which I was not even a
remotely I have a chance any of that
I just
all right all right all right all right
I'm not upset I'm not I'm not mad I'm
not mad I'm not mad okay
I'm not it's all good we're gonna do
role models next we'll come back to
trivia murder party okay we will we'll
come back to that
I just all these are new I got to figure
out what's going on with what we got
going on
let's do extended timers family friendly
that's for losers
okay I think we're good oh I just wish
wish
Hey okay three two one here we go we're
going for it
I just wasn't I wasn't big beefy until I
just take a picture
okay sure that's good enough okay it's
good did it go okay there it is no no
wait I can do that a little better here
we go
this is a new feature though oh wait no
I broke it I'll guess what it crashed oh
yay oh it crashed baby okay here we go
that's perfect okay this is much better
I got a better picture guys there we go
okay all right I have no idea what this
game is about but I put extended timers
on and you can still join in the
audience so if you want to play join
with that code at jackbox TV and let's
go everybody's in alright let's do this
I don't like the hands hi welcome to
role models lab goggles are necessary
for safety otherwise I'll get lost in
your eyes here at the lab we've spent
years searching for the genetic magic
that makes each and every human a truly
unique individual but that was hard so
we found a shortcut
we theorize every friend group has some
version of the smart one
the troubled loner who I can change also
the idea and these roles make it a lot
easier to figure people out with science
you guys are going to match your fellow
test subjects to the roles that fit them
best my lovely assistant will put all
the data into the tubes and at the end
we'll crunch the numbers and tell each
of you who you really are
oh okay the lab stuff some fresh
cadavers coming at 9:00 so let's go wait
what I need a category to get us started
it won't be your favorite but try to
make it something everybody knows a
little bit about oh yeah this is obvious
this is clearly obvious this is so
obvious everyone knows this everyone
already knows what the deal is about
this so I don't think there's any
question about what's going on here
why Matt I don't know the thing about
geometric shapes why would anybody know
that who represents each geometric shape
why so on your device you've got the
names of your fellow lab rats dragging
one to the role you think fits them best
and you'll see a little 99 % next to
each roll top that to lock in the answer
you're 99% certain will match what
everyone else picks I'll make it worth
your while if you're right so make sure
to pick someone when everyone's giving
out their roles we'll check out the
results wait we have 63 seconds why do
we waste extended timers in the 15
seconds or five years why why is it got
to be that different okay whatever okay
um okay I'm so confused
[Music]
okay okay I got it I don't know what
this means
show me the votes get rid of the
outliers that's our winner okay I like
to keep my guinea pigs motivated so I'll
give you guys these nutritious science
pellets whatever your answers match the
group whoever has the most at the end is
my lab rat of the month plus they taste
like meat oh and you're 99% guess was
100% right what what what and you got
the role with the audience bonus pellets
you're one advanced skinny pig I'm so
confused
I have no idea how this works okay one
day you'll grow up to be a rectangle
should I be insulted that I'm square I
think I feel like I should be insulted
by that you're very sharp okay guys this
yeah you think this game was meant for
straight friends and not strangers I
think you might be right about that
let's lose these votes
most of your secrets will be buried with
you
[Music]
if I'm counting right that's a tie
time for another test to see who gets
this role people know these people guys
I don't know okay um I cast my vote I
think we all know I mean flicks is the
Kuip type of deserve some science
pellets arrow knows this I don't know
why you good science if there's one
thing that flip always does spoil their
dinner load comic chart general I salute
you I have a feeling this is leading up
to something not on represent sure what
all right we've got our lineup and
here's how you're doing on science
pellets okay remember winner you get
pellets when your answers match the
group or you perform the best in a
tiebreaker experiment keep that in mind
if you want to beat your fellow guinea
pig all right you got it
you stupid pieces of poop I'm gonna kick
your crap I'm gonna beat your not what
oh we just do it again okay well that's
a tie
okay don't know this paper how would
each of you obtain superpowers okay make
those matches and remember to tap the
99% button next to the combo you feel
most strongly about ok I'll be you know
I'm gonna make an executive decision I'm
gonna make an executive decision I think
okay I think this game is supposed to be
played with friends and that I do not
have I don't have friends I don't have
any friends it to be honest so I'm gonna
go with the idea that that game is not
for me
we're gonna move on to a game called
joke boat which if if I'm reading it
correctly as a game all about bad jokes
so there we go right right okay good
great good no no no I have no friends
all right give me a second okay
hang on welcome aboard I'm Chuck hull
the ship's captain and MC grab your
dummy and sign in and I'm signing in
[Music]
okay three two one go we don't have oh
wait
three two one yeah we do have all day
actually we have as much time as I want
so whatever I don't like that mine looks
like the looks like the puppet from the
saw to these people so again I have no
idea how this game goes I don't know
what it means I don't know what it
entails but I think it's gonna be fun
for the whole family and we're one big
happy family that's how this works as
soon as you hit that subscribe button
you become part of a family an Ohana any
time which means family I think all
right here we go ready you can still
join once we start the game maybe
[Music]
gather round comedians here's tonight's
itinerary we're gonna write some jokes
and then test them out on stage all
right things first
it's brainstorming time Before we jump
into the jokes let's do a little writing
exercise to get inspired on your device
you'll be prompted to write various
topics like animals people or objects
fill in whatever you think has a lot of
comedic potential if another player uses
one of your topics in a winning joke
you'll get some bonus points generate as
many as you can you have 45 seconds
starting now I have a funny feeling this
is not kind of
[Music]
okay okay anybody know how to spell
boudoir all right I've realized because
I'm trying to type this I'm not very
clever uh you've got time for one or two
more bits for tonight's competition the
steps on your device to construct two
jokes
uh-huh Oh God
[Music]
well I realize people don't have okay
all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
after homebody Josh drives right Oh God
Oh - I thought it said seven okay all
right ooh dangerous
[Music]
ah man these are not funny no God these
are not funny
Oh God these are not funny oh so unfunny
okay your second joke yet now would be
the time working on it I'm so unfunny oh
god I'm sorry the least amount of funny
it's what I've got here
[Music]
I don't know I did my best
we've corralled some great comedy for
you at the inside please give it up for
our first comic oh god oh my god oh god
this is happening
oh god this is really happening oh my
god don't forget your catchphrase oh my
god why are they called B's and not I'll
[ __ ] that hurts oh my god my favorite
joke now
[Laughter]
[Music]
phrases are better than the jokes all
you did was pick the obviously funnier
so I want to open a store that only
sells Bob and call it bobbin out y'all
like Mike okay judges render your
verdict
[Music]
oh yes sorry all right well how where am
I gonna put my my camera kit how do i
geez tip of the hat to you how you like
my game our next comic needs an
introduction Oh what do I
I'll perform the joke I like my friends
like I out God I like my crews is filled
with diseases I have to leave because I
like media all right ordered Wireless I
put it in the middle here right here you
shall be judged buddy
I win I'm the best clearly I was vastly
superior clearly I am in fact the best
coming up right now we're hot comedy
okay okay guys here we go here we go
guys oh damn he ID'd have you heard
about the succulent challenge seat
grotty Walter that's where you suck
weighted Wireless wrong okay oh god no
oh god no where the butt cross oh god I
[Music]
thought I'd have like a chance to choose
I thought it I just threw that away it's
our next comic what's the difference
between most people and boobs missiles
[Applause]
okay okay good watermelon here we go my
nickname is still though I should be
good because I'm hard I think that's the
point
but it still feels bad it still feels
bad all right there we go
yeah that's good that's good I feel like
that's just I feel like it's just a fair
world if that's the case for you as well
for me
here's another comedian whether you like
it or not I don't like it to be
perfectly honest I think I don't like it
at all I have more memes than the
dankest of hipsters hipsters are the
meme types I don't know if that's
exactly in their repertoire gotta hate
my bulkhead I'm gonna get it cut
eventually when I was a kid we didn't
have socks
we have blenders
and it's the spicy baby all right you
won me over [ __ ] god what's happening
this is a terrible the Savile
everything's horrible everything in the
world is terrible that wasn't bad
what I mean that wasn't bad fairly I
don't know what funny is like say you
had it's that's the spicy baby really
wanted over I always would you ever
noticed how AG czar just a fancy version
of cows walk into a bar
and it was utter chaos dad things
spelled uttered
I don't know what's happening I don't
know who's who anymore I don't know what
the deal is with anybody but yeah that
that's fitting that that makes sense
crushed it rusty frosted crushed it
great setup an actual job all right
let's hear it for our next comedian here
we go I'm ready
mildewed how many swords does it take to
change a lightbulb three one screw it in
two two three
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay we're hitting it we're hitting our
stride guys we're hitting it we're
really getting into the main comedy
forget in there guys it took a while but
we got here we got there we got it yeah
you can play you just gotta go to jack
box to be and plug it the code oh let's
look at our starboard that's a book joke
my life is in shambles
mine too ah this is ship shaping up to
be a hot night of hoots and hollers man
you gotta stop talking are we still
going well
well we're sinking again there's no time
to write jokes from scratch Oh God
here's the plan
let's rewrite another comics joke you'll
use the same Center but we'll attempt to
write a funnier punchline I've got it
are the original joke did the more
points you learn for beating me can you
steal the spotlight before the boat
sinks yes yes I can
I'm ready
[Music]
okay I'm ready for this I've got this
Oh God I have no idea how to rewrite
this joke I'm so unfunny Oh God
Oh God
[Music]
okay I did my best I don't know where
didn't go in the lifeboats first
everyone else stick around and welcome
back our performers wait so this is just
an audience full of men is that what
you're saying okay here we go
my love life is like markiplier great
look love it short they successfully
beat this joke vote now go away this
gotta be like a button that just tonight
is their way to delete a live stream
[Applause]
I don't know a group of cows walk into a
bar did you just fix the spelling and
all were in an utterly what do you think
does this joke beat the original how how
do I try the audience is stupid how do
how I don't like delete a live stream
from ever happening how do i erase this
from all of you oh boy here we go I'll
perform the joke I got okay never mind
my nickname is still though because I'm
the only thing your mother loves oh just
gonna go crawl and die thank you I'm
going over there to die alright here we
go get somebody get us off this boat
when I was a kid we didn't have socks we
had condoms what
when you were a kid what none of these
mix I can't see mine was any better so I
don't know I don't know man I know I'm
dying man we're sure you okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
look at her here we go
or the catchphrase I miss the
catchphrases I want to open a story that
only sells Bob and call it toupees bye
Bob dude I don't know what this is I
have no idea what this is you think I
know what this is
anybody is I don't know all I know is
said I'm not funny all I know that is
that I've been proven to be unfunny
along with everybody else here no one's
[ __ ] have you heard about the
succulent challenge that's where you
suck someone off during Lent
oh my god we've been abandoned
we are desolate Rock spinning off in
space no one will remember us for our
accomplishments no one will be forgotten
we will be left behind and forgotten in
all the funny gods have left us we've
been abandoned everything we know and
love is God I like my friends like I
like my cruise is funny frozen and gone
[Applause]
intelligent an intelligent species this
is evidence to the contrary we are the
wind on my great joke by few points
really ah God God is dead and we killed
him comedy God is dead and we've killed
her
whoever get to the other ass cheek
you think you could be peepee poo-poo
[ __ ] you think
pee pee poo poo fine we'll go down you
idiot you fool he won't be baby poo poo
far peepee poo-poo fart is unbeatable
no baby poo poo heart I can't believe
this you can get a light fast what
why if I'd not be poop of fart will live
on I would have won if not for peepee
poo-poo fart guys I'm not funny I may
not be funny but now I know that all of
you guys aren't funny as well so we're
all in the same boat ha ha ha ha ha
we're all in the same boat of not
funniness so that's good that's great in
fact we're all not funny nothing funny
is anything here we funny ups for to say
in Han Google hyung Google Heil
oops all funny
oops oo is it's chemi ops all that's
what it is
eagle soon Jenni up saw it's not funny
not interesting at all
great good this go away
go get I'm out here dwarf everybody just
delete that from your brains everyone
delete it from your brains all right we
got one more new one another new game
just delete it from your brains okay you
guys ready
this one's called
dictionary dictionary dictionary I'm
really emphasizing the dick on this but
it's not emphasized in the game
dictionary
it's called dictionary dictionary
dictionary dictionary I'm dick scenario
dick scenario dictionary dictionary of
[Music]
dictionary dictionary dick scenario dick
shun area dictionary oh I don't know how
this game works but let's do it here we
go welcome to the dictionary 'm if words
were muffins this would be a place where
you make muffins oh yeah I am thrilled
to see the team looking so freaking
fresh in the dictionary 'm you are in
charge of defining and creating words at
the end of the game you'll have worked
together to create a whole new
dictionary entry but obviously like
there is a winner it's a game if you're
just watching right now join the
audience enter the room code and play
along ok let's begin let us begin
alright I'm giving you a new word ok
so we're making up words is what you
should own a definition that you think
fits this word oh oh this this word at a
mall in Wisconsin
[Music]
relax you're making up words the only
way to mess up is if you accidentally
create a real word like Wonka or gazebo
[Music]
I've got it I've done it I'm a genius
I'm a genius everybody I've done it I am
glorious if there's one thing I'm good
at its making up random [ __ ] now you
might be thinking why was I not good at
doing this thing that I'm stating I'm
good at in the last game well that's
because that's not random [ __ ] I'm
trying to make duck here I'm making a
random [ __ ] show that's that's what
I'm doing here that is refreshing okay a
rash on your ass from grass a crash
landing on astroturf really the act of
cutting the crusts off the PB&J sandwich
without consent the definition that best
fits the word or you know that's not
what I wanted chuckling what no no no I
did no wait no what no it's not censored
what no I didn't want that what I
thought I was sorted Oh bonus points to
the one that's guys dude I didn't want
that I was trying to pick it I didn't
want this there's no uncensor button
what dude I'm sorry that's my bad that's
my bad that's my bad that's my bad guys
listen guys please forgive me
guys forgive me guys please forgive me
right guys
guys please please forgive me please I
didn't want it I I didn't guys winning
definition is guys guys please you have
process for our other word all right
boots [ __ ] a slang term for bad
jokesters including marker but I don't
know why you have to particularly the
feeling you get when you bang your funny
bone
I just the sensation of being snapped on
the buttocks by a towel I just the
scream of a six-year-old kid falling off
a building I guys please vote for your
favorite guys our very favorite
definition guys I just guys I please
couch all right bad I feel I feel bad I
feel bad I didn't mean for it to be this
way I'm sorry
[Music]
I'm sorry
do you forgive me you forgive me thank
you thank you so much thank you thank
you
it takes so long to decide thank you no
I'm not still in Korea I'm back home I
made a video that was sick I'm home
haha you've all been bamboozled
haha you've all been flim flu so that
was mine
ah I win I'm wet
you don't deserve to win to 9x someone
I'm not naming who but someone decided
to censor the winner
our words have the same meaning as
another word synonym give me another
word that could mean the same thing as
the definition on your device this round
is quick let's go let's go okay all
right
[Music]
okay I got it my genius answer is here
but guys synonyms synonyms a guys listen
I - enjoy the thrilling okay pick the
word that makes the most sense with this
definition if I censor everything that
means that I could win by default right
I have this magical power
[Music]
with fish blowing snap chub buttocks and
twang Kerr
I feel like Quaker is a bad word but I
don't know enough to call it out so I'm
just saying it out of ignorance you've
been but oxd who's taking a long time to
vote
who's doing this who in this is taking
forever to vote I put on extended timers
for you and you're not even vote vote
already
no cheating a lot I didn't cheat I
haven't cheated I would never short I
wouldn't do it Oh interesting
and the winning synonym is interesting
you've been buttocks bumble humble
cinnamon tumor
[Music]
the audience extends the answers that
that makes sense that makes sense so who
in the audience is being a lazy poop and
Nabu right now is up away from their
device getting a snack who's doing that
who's doing that because that's
offensive in every sense of the
you oh well that makes sense
[Music]
come on fold already know you've been
fooled you've been bamboozled I am Lorna
oh you all look so silly right now wow I
am the winner
oh you've been gobble tumbled backbone
flam definition let's use it right the
sentence that incorporates the word on
your device in turn thank you i sentence
you to writing a sentence
[Music]
I'm a genius
I am so goddamn smart wait wait wait
wait wait
submit ho ho I am a goddamn genius I me
amazing just wait to pop my peepers on
decent this is a popular one I tried to
catch the Leprechaun and steal their
gold but tripped and ended up taking a
bumble tumble pretty good mom my uncle
goes to bumble tumble again what no it
wasn't sexual this time oh no mark don't
play in the grass your box will be
bumble tumbled into oblivion Jack and
Jill would I be able to fetch a pail of
water Jack fell down in bubble tumbled
this crown and Jill came bumble tumbling
after you wrote now you vote one of
these is amazing one of these is
terrible
[Music]
thank you I know I'm amazing I'm amazing
I know I'm aware of this
[Music]
I started screaming 69 minutes ago I
hate I am weak everyone in the audience
I hate I hate everyone I hate every one
of you I hate every one of you every one
of you every one of you is like six
years old and you're all just a bunch of
that's you right now I put bone into
mine
Jack and Jill been bumbling tumbling all
over each other
I'm a genius you guys are squandering my
genius here you guys are you guys are
insulting Mike the depths of my big
brain you guys I'm wasting my huge brain
on you whoa uncle I just sure
Wow just I can't believe I waste my
incredible my incredible talent on you
guys
why waste I wish my incredible my
incredible genius brain when you die boy
stuck dude you're squandering your
potential and the victorious sentence is
what the terrific entry in the
dictionary 'm you should be proud behold
this perfection you truly have a gift
let's forget gratitude who won ha ha I
still win because I'm the greatest and
also both of my entries made it into the
dictionary I want to say I just found a
dozen words hiding in my shag carpeting
I'm finally appreciated once and for all
I my talents have been appreciated in
the living room pull up the stool or
chair iam with lots of foods and
beverages like milk or juice or barrier
that's read to make your crazy words and
don't forget to varium and that is how
you win a dictionary 'm
[Music]
you've got to be creative sense of humor
is necessary your definitions must stand
out we don't want Arden areum to finish
as the winner well you can't be second
barium you've got to be the boss don't
settle for the secretary
anyone can play a baby or a centenarian
play it with your friends or even with
your adversary us any time of year is
fine in May or January oh there's no
excuse to not play dictionary dictionary
[Music]
by the time you finish playing you will
be extraordinary your brain will be
gigantic Miriam snow upon you doctorates
honorarium at spelling bees they'll
spell your words you will be legendarium
so cancel all your meetings and clear
your itinerary I'm throwing a party
right away waste not the moment areum
get ready to have so much fun it's
really kind of scary Oh join hands and
sing the song of fiction area okay good
all right cool and with the part that's
great okay we're going back to trivia
murder party first I want to say a
shout-out to and a thank you to bash -
pecan Nathaniel Johnson can you please
come to Utah sometime I don't think for
any particular reason
oh wait sir I don't think I'd be going
to Utah for any particular reason thank
you - waffles love you mark your videos
never fail to make our days brighter oh
thank you so much and thank you to Zack
Matusik mark you are an amazing person
that I'm grateful to have known about
and watched all these years keep on
getting on oh thank you there's no need
for them thank you
I don't think I'll be getting to Utah
anytime soon but thank you all right
we're going back to trivia murder party
we've tried all of them and my
suspicions were confirmed trivia murder
party is by far the best but I think we
all knew that because trivia martyr
murder party was the best before as well
I'm gonna put on extend timers this time
just to give people a little more little
more moment to contemplate what they're
doing
and I want to see what happens if the
audience can actually win which I think
the the extended timer should help okay
who's ready let's see what happens this
time mark up look up star citizen I know
you love space this game is all space
well thank you but also I have a who
[Music]
okay thank you though
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can join in any time if you want to
join in the audience
[Music]
[Applause]
alright one of the things this is your
Wicca pole for pill to die that I think
no one will ever feel so the book was
like classic hotels magazine was a fake
willing you here to fight for your life
for now only one of you will survive
well put the memories we create will
live on forever
alright first question okay where's your
ACO these are the bars to answer the
question huh you in the audience
audience to can apparently win this time
whereas in the first one you could not
win so there's that possibility but very
burpee at the moment but i don't know
how that's gonna go
oh and refrain from shouting the answer
in the chat because uh you guys that's
not how you play you gotta push it on
your mobile device
you're silly Billy's moisture droids
I actually feel free to shot whatever
you want because no one's gonna get it
completely right and that means
everyone's gonna be okay goodbye
see you around I'm going to dictate a
message to you write down as much of why
I say as you can the player who writes
the fewest of my words will die ah get
your typing fingers ready because I'm
starting right now
I don't can't attend a local joggers if
you are tired of discovering horrible
crimes during your early warning rods I
recommend you avoid the path next to
Davis woods I know you are trying to get
in shape and cannot waste time being
interviewed by detectives huh
turns up
now let me just see what we have here
with the flicks and what's the result
oh this is not good
I mean I could bang my head on the
typewriter and get something better than
this
oh wow that was pretty bad guys you
didn't even try
hey you're toast no but love options
wait and you just might steal someone
else's life listen win the game you
don't know that
Oh also there's an audience in the game
if they survive you die
hot tip you can join the audience at any
time you can check box TV code why yrw
let's keep moving okay let's do this
what is not part of a battery man you
guys in the audience would have to be
really unified if you actually wanted to
be able to win this welcome back to The
Killing room let's use all of my cousin
Aloysius Azad stage props
pick a space inside the box too hard
some spots are better than others but
don't over think it oh boy I think I
know what this box is about I have a
funny feeling it involves swords
oh come on
coyote you need some helpful volunteers
you get a sword to run your sword oh oh
oh I thought there was a knife Oh God
have women death I'm the best I was
raised in a family of hotel Oh need
serial killers I never really fit in I
always wanted to kill people in other
places they never really got me oh I
should tell that in a boss story slam
okay
let's try another one as weird one was
velcro patented easy not not easy the
opposite of easy how did everyone know
that doesn't make any sense
and Celine's just dumb so it can read
which word comes from an Australian
Aboriginal language I'm sorry what
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry what I'm sorry what haha oh
don't kill me please head upon a down
death please anything but those sweet
embrace of consequences now we learn
obedience follow as many rules as you
can before time runs out everyone else
is playing too if any of them correctly
follow more rules than you I will kill
you and it's already begun the weasel on
your device now please of our right
[Music]
we time is coming to an end
ah hey evil meat I'm so good I'm so
great I am the best and you're dead
yes I'm gonna lose it in the end I know
I know I'm gonna lose it in the end I
know this I lose it in the end
where's here's left alive we go to the
final round which actor directed a white
point I don't think this is right I
don't tricky trick I feel like it's a
tricky trick button Oh he dresses it -
OH
I mean I got it right but I want to show
you something whatever he wants to show
you it's probably not good
just be aware hate for 20s things let's
see if the safe players are good at
forgery okay the ghost of my Aunt
Mildred loves to write words on mirrors
pay attention to her unique handwriting
now Aunt Mildred just went to write a
different word but so will everyone else
draw a word on the mirror to camouflage
Aunt Mildred
go ahead and start writing pay attention
to the words as they appear and try to
spot my auntie words to choose from I
think it might be tootin guys guys I
think it's tootin I got a honey feeling
that it's Tooting with the wheel Aunt
Mildred please stop Oh God
I tricked everyone in the audience to
five which is salt and I'm sorry what
what I think it's a trick question
got me right oh oh
guys wait wait hang on guys stop hey no
I don't stop guys wit no why do I always
spin the loser wheel why why do I always
sprinkle around it's fun I just I feel
like this is unfair I feel like it's
unfair I feel like everybody in the
audience I'm sorry what
[Music]
I'm sorry wait way but I'm lucky no I'm
amazing it's the answer that you're
looking for I'm not lucky I'm amazing I
am amazing that's just the only answer
I'm amazing I am unstoppable I am I am
unbeatable I am the best there ever was
I am beyond everybody's ability to be my
glue them stupid god damn it I don't
want to go in the room again I don't
want to go in the room I don't want to
go in the room I don't want to go I
don't want to go in the room I'd rather
not be here time to try to save yourself
with the password with your device we
could hurt a guess if your password get
splat you die now if we try to crack the
password as a team just the password on
your device I feel like you'll never get
it you just as a lever to the right
you'll never get it you'll never get it
it's to you you've all are dumb I I am
the genius here
there's no shouting out loud if you can
but you will not - you're so dumb all of
you too stupid to be able to no way all
of you are dumb ah get rekt
losers all of your stupid I am
unbeatable because my big brain picks
the best words I am beyond every of you
stop I will never be I will never be
beaten
[Music]
movie features the characters makes one
cookie flag in Harlan pepper lucky no
that was genius all skill all skill all
day all skill all day unbeatable skill
unstoppable skill in Vacaville skill no
one's better
no one knows no one knows nothing better
everyone who's on my side is gonna get
free ice cream we're all part of this we
not always got it oh we are the best
there ever was
oh you are now everyone is on my side
gets free ice cream and that is
promising places is totally badass
because it does not observe daylight
savings time
I am the greatest that there ever was
and everyone who believes that it's
gonna come with me and we're gonna go
get a free buffet I'm gonna buy out the
whole buffet restaurant we're all gonna
get an all-you-can-eat buffet
it's gonna have all you can eat chicken
wings and vegan options and it's gonna
be great great loss for everybody
including vegan milkshakes if you don't
want that never had one
bye bet it's not that bad yes what sucks
oh wow it's checkout time but too many
of you are still alive what's fix that
if I get screwed over on random chance
on these last ones I'm gonna begin I'm
gonna be very upset you've been very
resilient but only one of them can
survive this game uh-huh
I can't one of these keys will open the
lock to your tank I don't like it good
thing I'm a genius okay how is that fair
I waited oh I'm glad to see you're the
one to make it here alive or will you be
the one to escape
[Applause]
if a ghost catches you he'll steal your
life force that they can try to escape
and win the game is everyone's next
question and they get a third chance out
from cats up to you Harden's oh stop
I need hair gel that's what I need are
you I need to get the shark fin back so
I'm gonna get drama go back with your
never mind I'm gonna anger morph back
into 2013 I'm gonna kick your ass boy oh
jeez I'm gonna kick your butt
I'm calming a ghost kick you right in
the butt to cos your butt tuchus is
about to be kicked
o get rekt here comes the dad manager
coming at you hard hot and heavy oh here
comes trouble in the shape of my ass
you should feel threatened listen he
woods I'm gonna kick your ass from here
to Tuesday with my yes yes get ready to
reap the punishment of my really
stressful in here a lot of Lucky guesses
get ready to keep no I don't know but it
may be I dunno because I smart I am
which is incredibly smart I'm gonna kick
your teeth oh [ __ ] well maybe not turns
out I might be stupid rules alright get
a face full of my ass because it's about
to see your ass in your grave you're
gonna have an ass shaped grave with my
ass put it on your tombstone speak oh do
you smell - oh right get ready for a
whole heap in helping to mass in your
eyes I'm gonna kick there's gonna be
your ass Coosh
you get at it ah god damn it alright
it's a star baby girls I'm time to beat
you into the dirt because I'm so smart
I'm gonna kick your ass with my ass get
ready for a face full of can I do it Oh
[Laughter]
but who care I care what I did it I did
it I can't I did it I kicked your ass
from here Tuesday I kicked your entire
ass with my ass I did I did it with a
come-from-behind victory I have secured
my entire future I have done it I did it
I did it so good I did it so good oh I
did it I did it
I did it
okay apparently that doesn't work but I
did it cuz I am the best
let's go again everybody let's do this
hard hot heavy and fast I'm on the I'm
on the AMA I'm on a winning streak I'm
feeling it I'm feeling good I'm feeling
good are you feeling good at home
because you should we're all feeling
good because we know that we're doing
amazing things here yeah we're feeling
it I'm feeling it you're feeling it
we're all feeling it get it here
everybody we're about to be limited I
would like to officially thank everybody
that believed in me in that last round
because without your belief I would have
had no chance in the history of ever to
be able to win that that was in all of
us win that was in all of us win we all
did it
I'll be right back okay - but ammo Eric
you talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
this is your wake-up call the pill to
die
welcome to to the another party you're
free we can get away with a trap value
into a game of life or death only one of
you survived I'm running a hotel and
killing people I've achieved work/life
balance okay first question what was
Saturn the god o new device to answer
the question I've done it again I'm I've
done it I've done it good I'm Earth Mars
I'm no I'm not dead I'm back and I'm
ready I'm so ready
don't question right the rest of you
might not be my game for two and if
anyone matches you you die and I do mean
anyone uh oh god um
I I'm blanking what is the what is the
name of what's that country I can't
remember what the country was okay if I
die in the first in the first what movie
is about a party where somebody gets
murdered okay I got this one
Oh God
nailed it I'm a genius my big brain is
rolling at a hundred and thirty thousand
percent capacity I'm killing it every
which way from Sunday I'm killing Sunday
to Friday every day is another day to
murder retains another day I take
advantage of so let's do this let's do
this hard hot heavy and fast it's tattoo
time Ted it's gone to get some eat with
a wheel bad board never say that again
give me a new tattoo buy corn on your
device why can't I draw - don't grow
stop yeah wait stop stop stop
harder stop stop stop
[Music]
[Laughter]
what did we decide it's gonna be the
penis it's just gonna be worse after
heels I will have my revenge
move by camp I'm sorry I can't
there's literally no place I can put it
I guess it doesn't matter you to myrrh
very good streamer
I just want to be a girl I'm trying to
be a good streamer
I don't know where you want my FaceCam I
don't know where you want it I don't
know where here is this going to here
this is this good news for you there's a
bear here I'll move it wherever you want
wherever you want I'll move it I move it
I'll move it so good in this oh there
with joy I was in the ways there here we
go
I don't to be in the way of the content
oh god forbid you have to look at my
face instead of something I better go on
the green by my new way whose good arm a
salon before you die let's go okay I've
got this and so smart
I'm so smart
keep concentrating of all that now focus
on them now
we type of one or two wants makes around
I did it looks like you out there
oh wow that was pretty good I didn't do
too good there
Sarris two folks took it hello good
either way oh my god I'm in the way
Oh God how about doing this I'm sorry
I'm such a live shooting genius I'm such
a goddamn amazing live streamers
no one's ever live streams as hard as
I've livestream before I'm just such a
professional streamer but I provide you
the river okay fine I'll be right back
employers left alive we go to the final
round right there next question perfect
words Tunisia
I don't know go ahead and say I don't
know
put your facecam exactly where it should
be it's not hard I'm trying tourist and
trying guys to try and find so hard
I try you've been entered in my scratch
ticket giveaway scratching find three
dollar signs to live if he keeps racking
I'll give you cash for every dollar sign
you find Wow but if you scratch off even
one skull you die Oh looks like mom
shouldn't be playing the lottery looks
like mom maybe made mistake by mom oh
good hold up yeah
it's time good thing I'm in last good
Thank You Phoenix last but can you
escape no let's see the right answers
coldly did you think it was going to be
just you if the post catches up with you
they didn't steal your white force
everyone's next question guys
Lord I'm laughing it jump oh that's
where the real cuts it I'm gonna call
Ethan and ask him to do a full jump Oh
guys if she was so bad
types of water oh my god jump oh good
okay anyway Wow
I got that right here comes the dog I
don't think the audience is ever gonna
be able to win no offense to you guys
windows of loopholes burglars Mimi
Imfurst
[Laughter]
- who's running for office
I'm gonna die here I'm gonna be lost to
the abyss but regardless hey I got it
hey good for me the killer won't let
Gustavo I mean maybe you never know
Unidas seven chakras
I don't know what any chakras Oh
[Music]
the tables have told ya well for me ya
think I'm so we're gonna make it in
there one Tom he was prejudiced
where I died I got a jump oh really Taft
was only one term roasting oils Oh bleep
we took this money
my entire audience uh uh audience we
roll
I don't remember oh good none of them
great that's good to know
oh there goes the audience by audience
apparently I don't know I don't know I
don't know guys you weren't supposed to
jump all into the darkness didn't you
know
oh wow this is a close game apparently
would you think Google if you want to
play through the video you'll be to put
the field sir to this question everybody
needs the photo so choice Mel - I mean
this one's fairly easy so if you get it
wrong I feel bad for you
all right bear fair fair bear is fair
why'd you have to blow up the entire
hotel all right good good great good
feel good about that I could have ended
it on I could have ended it on such a
high note I could have been like hey I
won that's great this is so good gives
so good so happy I'm happy I've kind of
been like that guys we could have been
like that but it wasn't like that guys
he was like - like that - done
[Music]
right sorry I'm just I'm a little rabid
today I don't know why I guess it's it's
it's I'm feeling good because I back
home I'm back able to make that sweet
delicious delectable content just for
you just for you any live that sweet
delectable moon content means that
occasionally I lose it's fine it's okay
it's a hundred percent all right it's
all good it's fine it's all good so
unfortunately I'm out of time for now
but I wanted to say thank you guys so
much for joining me on this wonderful
livestream I got a little early access
to this I would like to play more of
this ah
but I'd also like to play with my
friends cuz there are some games in here
that might be better with friends and
some that might not be but thank you
everybody so much I've got a lot of cool
stuff waiting for you in the very near
future just thank you everybody so much
for being here
being awesome and just generally being
patient as I get my stupid butt took is
back from Korea but I'm here now and
it's going to be a very special month I
think you're gonna like a lot of the
things that are coming your way so look
out for some sweet delectable stuff
coming very soon but just thank you guys
so much I want to get back into doing
just kind of hanging out with you guys
stuff doing more vlogs just to talk with
you and just being able to hang out is
one of the things that it's very easy to
take advantage of and take for granted
on YouTube in this reckless pursuit to
making better content which for some
reason I'm not doing because better
content I don't even know what that
means but just thank you guys you're
amazing
I'm really happy to be back um in a
really good place and I feel really good
about this stuff that I've been making
lately and you know I'm just I'm just
really proud of what I've been able to
accomplish what I've been able to make
with you guys helps - thank you
everybody so much sending a lot of love
your way if you haven't seen yet there
is a new episode of edge of sleep
available right now I put a link in the
description if you haven't checked out
edge of sleep and you like spooky scary
stuff much like trivia murder party here
with mysteries abound you might want to
check it out it's a story podcast an
audio drama that you can listen to the
first three episodes are available right
now and new episodes every Tuesday
link in the description it's called the
edge of sleep and you can check it out
linked right down below so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
bye guys bye bye bye
oh wait bye